so a guy's playing golf and he goes man
I [__] hit this guy in the middle of
the I was playing by myself in the end
of the day
and I couldn't
like I couldn't see anybody so I hit
this shot but it didn't go high it kind
of went [__] hard and straight I go
over and there's these two guys uh one's
on the ground holding his back he's not
moving and the other guy is standing
over him and they were uh wearing those
uh like the old time
pants what are they called
um
uh no they were white guys
[Applause]
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
hola With Me George Lopez let's do the
show because I got a lot of things to do
the thing I gotta go to that dry cleaner
by Keith Phelps
new sport sport and Paul
you know George is oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Robert George Lopez oh my God OMG
that's all this [__] is talking
trash about Beverly Hills I love people
that say [__] in a in a sentence
yeah because because
you know even I was you know I'm all
Elvis obsessed so the colonel uh tells
they're doing that 69 special and
they're doing rehearsals and the kernel
goes to the the producer and the Elvis
he goes it just occurred to me
that none of the 20 songs are [__]
Christmas songs
this whole idea for the show is what is
it's a Christmas show yeah so I I want
to see some Christmas songs not all 20
but I'd like to see some Christmas songs
in the Christmas show okay
neither of them said anything and they
both walked away and they got about out
of earshot and Elvis looked at that guy
Mike bender and said [__] him
[__]
you know I went back to visit him
an old friend of mine female she was
living back in Virginia she quit the
department went back and yeah that's big
yeah he did a computer sister was an
anchor for uh channel
so when I was in junior high I don't
know how we started saying it but they
would say hey so my teacher said big
tits yeah and they would go what we were
12 ago they go
like medium okay but now I've I've been
doing it since [__] junior high so
now I found a guy that and I do it here
he'll answer and you answered uh you're
not so did you pick up the story good
good it's not huge but I mean
we're recording I could be talking about
a nun and he'll say that I got no one's
listening I think I get into trouble 10
[__] different ways
so I went back to see her uh by the way
welcome we'll get through again yeah
yeah hang on there buddy we'll call your
number yeah number two I went back there
to speak in the FBI Academy
so she picks me up we go out and we had
a great [__] time she had a water she
told me hey I know how much money you
make remember I used to work with you
and I don't want to embarrass you but
hey look I miss everybody I love you but
this helps me get along oh she had a
[__] wad of money and she's they were
opening restaurant number seven Mexican
restaurants over there and her only
competition was uh Taco Bell
and so she [__] started up the
[__] top yeah she was they were
making banking
so we go out there and we have a good
time we go to the comedy show the
comments matter of fact Louie Anderson
because of how I laughed awesome man
because of how I laugh he came over
after the show she was hey I'm going to
be here for a couple of days you come
back and say no partner I'm going wow
you know I remember communities would do
that I'm going back to L.A really I'm
going to be out there in two weeks here
come on out hey comp tickets I'll take
care of you don't worry because he liked
the laughter well she's sitting there
it's time to kick me out of the car and
time ago he says I gotta tell you I love
you but you know what I love most of all
she says cops out here when they get
pissed off or they're really angry they
say damn God damn it you know maybe
maybe a [__] but that's about it she
says you're out here and she said it's
[__] this [__] them all these
[__] she says I miss saying
[__] like you do back there yeah I I I
mean
yeah for sure sometimes [__] is
the only who's this [__] [__] I
don't know I I feel like they're that's
exactly why because it's like there are
certain times where you kind of have
like it just kind of fits with what
you're saying I even feel that was stand
up like where you you pull it back a
little bit but then when you do it it's
like yes now it's like an effect there
is uh yes you know like it it helps it
gives you a little more but yeah I
definitely I swear a lot
um on our on the podcast I I'm like
always like dude you are [__] cussing
up a storm I know do people keep tabs I
don't all I know is my mother does and
like she will be like she's like she
can't listen to it because I'll say [__]
so Anna but but they're you know I'm
like in the moment and she's really like
saying oh dear God this guy says too
much yeah yeah but I go to me I'm like
that's just like talking that's it is it
is that's not that's not anything that's
not planned and that's not you know
that's just how you talk I think it's I
think they're almost you know they're
almost like triggers or sensors in a
podcast yeah because if you're listening
and you're walking it can get a little
monotonous you have to have some
deviation in your voice and once in a
while you go don't tell me that
[__] did you know like there's a
joke about Jesus you know confessing and
goes God you're not used your name and
and Bane because I was playing golf and
I hit the first shot right in the middle
and then it was like you know it was a
part five and I'd never hit a shot that
far and I said oh my God it's like this
far and then God goes don't tell me you
missed a [__] putt yeah
pick up the red phone for pizza
and the other one I know you're like
this one so a guy's playing golf and he
goes man
I [__] hit this guy in the middle of
the I was playing by myself in the end
of the day
and I couldn't like I couldn't see
anybody so I hit this shot but it didn't
go high it kind of went [__] hard and
straight I go over and there's these two
guys uh one's on the ground holding his
back he's not moving and the other guy
is standing over him and they were uh
wearing those uh like the old time
pants what are they called
um
uh no they were white guys Aaron
Aaron what hey what time are you what
are you doing [__] next time
you ever heard it
even on the white shadow they go hey
that's they go with the white shadow and
Ken the white shadows yeah I can't
believe you guys are in knickers and he
goes what did you say
I went to a country club to go play golf
I can't believe you we were wearing
knickers man in this day and age bad you
couldn't say that no man come on there's
tons of [__] I was watching uh [__]
Eastbound and Down dude that show is
shocking that like
you were talking about that long ago
they were talking about [__] a little
kid they go hey I'm just I'm just
kidding you know I mean opening but like
the first oh I mean he's going nuts wow
yeah it's crazy it's crazy because it's
like when you I that show's not that
long ago and I remember watching it when
you came out it was seen it Eastbound
and Down it's about it's about how many
seasons go four they did three seasons I
think it's about Danny McBride you know
Danny McBride Tropic Thunder played the
explosive expert he had the bad ear he's
an actor I'll show you who he is you
know he's a he's funny [__] man good
dude
uh Danny McBride used to work at the uh
Hilton right here in Burbank he was a
night manager yeah that's right and then
he goes back to North Carolina after
that I think didn't he yeah yeah and
um he said he got I said was it hot the
first thing I said you know me I always
say I said uh was it haunted and he goes
I'm gonna tell you man I heard noises
one night I go up there
and I can't hear anything but I could
see things
oh yeah right yeah and he said when he
got in the elevator and he he hadn't
really left yet like all the buttons
were pushed in the elevator like he just
said there was some weird [__] up there
while I got a elevator I was like hmm
yeah I don't know especially if you're
working overnight now it's like that
your mind I don't I don't know it gets
in all the [__] buttons are pushed
which never happens
uh pronounce your name Gareth yep
is that uh Welsh funny you don't have
the accent no parents do I don't why
don't you have the accent grew up in
Wisconsin yeah so say I had it as a kid
oh you did yeah big time and then it
like
Wisconsin like started to harden those
O's uh let's hear it English yeah well
right and George you're all right mate
good to see you big knockers
she's got those big knockers mate
[Applause]
I'm not just talking about the thing you
use on the door either yeah that's an
awesome one yeah whenever I you know
this is kind of insulting too
you know your your lineage but whenever
I go to Nevada London and you've been on
the plane forever and there's always
somebody to meet you and they said well
you know flying enjoyable I always say
but did I just put on my phone
I only say it once though yeah and I do
it I do it if somebody has a British
accent yeah I do I don't care if I met
him I went to the gas station is that
all that's what my fault you came for
five months
and this guy wanted me to put it on a
wedge and they wouldn't let the guy goes
hey you can't put that on a wedge
because I was going to give him to
Trevor himmelman that he won the Masters
and they said I was gonna poop should I
just smell my fonts and uh and we just
put
w-i-y-l-t-smf
I think I said I think it's better like
that
um
I think you know
um it's always an interesting thing
whenever I we have a guest man uh Gareth
Reynolds um
it says comedian only but
podcaster yeah where it explicitly says
I'm only a comedian I don't like that
limitation I really don't like it either
I like to be open um I'll do anything
yeah um no but yeah I podcast I'm a
comedian actor I used to be but then I
kind of like that's what I went to
college for but then like we were sort
of saying before it's like
that's kind of one where you just go you
know if that comes my way great but I
don't pursue it really what about did
you not like it I didn't like I I like
acting I like doing that part of it but
I what I can't stand is like the
audition which is a big part of being an
actor you know do you have a uh I mean
it's always [__] nightmares man I
[__] auditioning yeah I started to go
like like without commercial acting I
wouldn't have been able to survive
living in Los Angeles but once it got to
the point where it was like
you know cons my friends who are actors
and the consistency of like going out
and auditioning I'm like I would rather
just have my time
even even every now and then getting a
role I would rather just not waste the
time auditioning because we're working
on the sides and all that other [__]
what commercials have you done I've done
shitloads I mean when I in my 20s let's
see what Gil would recognize you [__]
because you'll watch nothing a lot of TV
don't you watch a lot of TV girl no no I
don't like you watch porno or no in the
house uh no no I do a lot of porn
commercials so you would recognize me
yeah that's awesome yeah jizz Rags all
that stuff this is the right guy it's
like the ShamWow guy you see yeah yeah
this one right which actually he ended
up created the shamble to clean up uh
blood off of that crime scene
and you just we I got all the evidence
right here this little [__] right
yeah bring it out into like a little
sample into a [__] old bottle of
spark water bottle
um
uh yeah go let's so so yeah tons but
people but you know when people want to
come out here there's a ton of [__]
things you can do totally to be to to at
least get in the line of you know that's
why people are waiters yeah well and
what's like commercials people don't
understand it's not like that anymore
because now it's like pretty much famous
people are non-union there's still like
some commercial work but when I came out
here you could go to commercial
auditions and if you booked a commercial
audition you'd work one day and you
could literally make like a year salary
at a regular job in a day so it would
even pay better than you know if you
booked a pilot a commercial would pay
better than a pilot so like I use that
and I was like holy [__] like this is
gonna that was enough to kind of get me
through the leaner years before I really
like had time to actually do the things
I wanted to do you know you need years
to like gain the traction because I
wasn't doing stand-up in my 20s or
anything like that wow what what was uh
what was the first thing that you got
and did it come to an agenda it comes
or [__] like that no no it was uh it was
an agent and I think the first thing was
like honestly this like ages me so much
but it was like Netscape or something it
was like it was some like early internet
provider yeah you know I knew you knew
me like a [__] crock pot you put the
[__] disc in and come back to the
facts noise yeah
um but it was something like that and
then it was like the first big one was
like Taco Bell I did like three Taco
Bell commercials and then it was like
then then I had like time to like do
that you know for a while but but that
was like so you know feast or family I
mean that that money is like oh my God
it's saving you dude say I one time came
I was broke and I One Time came home
[__] and I had a check that that a
company hadn't paid me or whatever and
it was for Seven Grand and I was like
are you [__] like the difference in
my does like my attitude was like I'm
back you know [__] that's a lot of
money man dude I mean when you have you
are like watching what you eat and [__]
and you get a check for Seven Grand
you're like holy [__] and it was really
and then I you know I had other like it
really is just it was like the dumbest
work but the most money and it really
did like help sustain you know um and
then you uh um what is the what is the
thing with reading the stories so that's
my podcast that's what I do yeah I know
your podcast with uh with Dave here and
it's basically it's called the dollop
and and basically Dave reads a story
from American history to me and I don't
know what it's going to be and then we
just like I Riff on it and like and it's
crazy it's crazy every story is crazy
like you talk about liking like crime
[__] like there's so many stories on a
dog where you're just like what the [__]
is going on right you want girl to read
you a little story yeah Gil would you
would you read them some of the Night
Stalker oh man and he'll make up a
narrative to go with it
this is like see this is like an
audition now this just got pressure
filled feels like he doesn't well here
it was you read it out about something
about Wikipedia
so that it stays to a story that you're
not making it up right yeah well I was
gonna tell them the truth I don't know
it's almost like a Magic Castle there
they have this over there somewhere in
Hollywood like we go in there and it's
story time I don't know Mansion they
could the story time Hotel yeah and you
go in the party story The Comedy story
yeah something and you go in there but
are you the only one that does it that
does the story time thing like does it
no I think there's a lot of those what
yeah what the [__] this from this
it's like a psychic realm though I know
because your your sensors are firing you
never heard something and you're that's
where that's like my I mean it's super
weird but like that became like like
even my I used to do improv like when I
first moved to LA and people would be
like like that's like organized like
trying to come up but people would be
like you are like a funny guy to talk to
versus like funny on you know what I
mean so it's like I should have used
this [__] incredible talent for
something more
helpful to the society like at a
university I mean maybe I'm gonna get
around to it it's on my to-do list right
yeah I mean at some points value I mean
we're always saying I'm gonna do
something good for society he does
something that nobody [__] does it's
like someday it'll come in handy to help
things if it could produce water if I
want it
no
you can't he's this is the new
investigation of the Night Stalker
finding the story on it
well just I don't have wife I don't have
the Wi-Fi password here so it's like wow
you guys are caging with that iron Aaron
bring something up on the Night Stalker
Aaron we demand Wi-Fi
please
try try logging into no
okay no more Wi-Fi
um
uh no more Mr Wi-Fi do you love it I
love it I love it because like password
you know like he'll go over there
plus everyone will get the password
they'll be sitting out they [__] got
my [__] password from just the
cameras once I had to change it really
see isn't that some [__] [__]
everything up they're like hey man you
know you got to change your password
what was it for your phone and you're
like yeah and they could see it they
could see me do it that's a problem I
had to [__] it [__] everything up
and that is quite a process when you got
to do the full change it's like [__]
yeah
um but yeah I love it man I'm like
I mean I you know I was grinding it out
for a long time like not really I kind
of I I've been a writer for a while and
I was like basically writing TV [__] for
a while and I really liked it but I
always wanted to perform and I kind of
was just like that's not gonna happen
like you know I tried a lot and then um
and then I started doing a couple
podcasts and I was like doing stand-up
at the time but you know I was like
emceeing or featuring a little bit and
then once the dollop hit it was kind of
like holy [__] like I can you know use
this did you go to college to be to
learn writing I went I went to college
for acting which was like did you just
know the the English part of writing no
I just I just knew I just had written
sketch comedy so I like knew how and I
grew up like just watching TV like my
parents fought so I just watched Nick at
night growing up and I watched like Jim
Burrows shows all the time like I've
seen all taxi like cheers welcome back
you know what I mean like I just watch
all those shows and um and so my brain
even now when I'm writing stuff has this
like sitcom final draft I just know I
just know like that stuff and so and
that was really it as far as like
grammar and [__] that was just like
learned via you know spell check and
[__] really because I didn't I didn't
know writing I mean I I think I could
write a script if I sat down and did it
but I guarantee you you could but also I
used to write with paper without lines
because I just wanted to write yeah
right I didn't want to see the [__]
lines but I was just wondering right
yeah right and you know sometimes with
lines yeah and um but when you can write
funny I think they could find a place
for you even if you're not the best you
know they're like what a [__]
ellipses or all that other [__] I
don't know what the [__] that is or they
can even like restructure you know what
I mean like you give the heart of the
idea of the job they're like all right
yeah yeah I think that's that's yeah and
I guarantee you with the amount of [__]
you've done you could absolutely right
and then uh um could you have sustained
yourself would you be as happy if you
were just a writer no you wanted I want
I prefer I mean
yeah well you just like you feed off of
live energy I mean you cannot be like
even we go into our podcast live and if
you told me that that would ever happen
I would have been very strange but it is
like you cannot beat energy of live
reaction to either stuff you've written
or to like when you're riffing on stuff
or when you're doing crowd work you just
that to me is like the best version like
the dangerous version comes right are
you writing things down or do you have
recall in your mind I I think you can
keep recalling your mind right I do but
I'm like I do both I mean I I record
like every set I basically listen to
every set and I start to hate myself and
I hate my voice and I hate my words and
all that but it's like no longer form it
is like rehearsed and so but then yeah
then you were able to you know like when
you're writing on stage if you like have
a tag or a joke and you're just like and
even if you say it out loud or in your
head you're like that's it goes at the
end or you go that's way better or I was
just doing that last night where you say
if you say one thing early you can call
it back at the end if it's really good
if it's a really good or um yeah uh uh
yeah yeah
because I see that like um I transcribed
you ever do you ever go get them
transcribed I've never fully gotten it
transcribed I have actually transcribed
it myself how do you like there's a
[__] companies out there they're
gonna charge a lot yeah I transcribe
every show pretty much uh from the last
20 years every show you get transcripts
sometimes like like I did two shows on
Saturday and the first one the
microphone didn't work when I walked out
there is that a problem for a stand-up
comedian uh it can be a little bit of an
issue and now the back they couldn't
hear me in the back then they couldn't
hear me in the front and then I'm up
there now and I said hey
um I said what are you [__]
yelling at me for I [__] just got out
here yeah uh and then I left until they
[__] fixed it you left the stage yeah
yeah because that's a struggle yeah I'm
not going to be up here and I even told
my man Road manager who left the [__]
side of the stage I said what good are
you if when I have an issue you're not
in the room
where were you up in at the Hard Rock up
there in the late water wheatville
whatever [__] weak left it sounds
like Cream of Wheat [__] uh I
used to be married okay
and uh I told him after I got off what
do you say he [__] agreed yeah
I said I said you don't have an issue
[__] charging me every single [__]
penny but when I need you you're not in
the room somebody has to run and go get
you well that those days are over even
if you're [__] bored you're gonna
[__] sit there and you're gonna watch
because something goes wrong with the
microphone or another time I had covet
last New Year's Eve yeah and I had to
leave they had to go get them and where
was he [__] outside sitting down
talking to somebody else
[__] there you had to leave the
stage because you had coveted you felt
like yeah I was on fire man really
almost fainted you really like the Dale
Hughley one where he uh he went down I
didn't go down yeah but but also I saw a
red flash go by my [__] like they
said I was inviting me early and I'm
like that doesn't look [__] normal
like a sash of red you're like I think
it's like when your car when you're like
oh [__] what's going on and all the
lights go on yeah right you're like oh
this one your mind's dashboard yeah
that's that's what really made me get up
that was [__] week I sat down I
couldn't remember anything to say that
that's another one right and then I saw
this red streak go by and I was like
uh I think I better that's my time maybe
good night I gotta take I gotta leave of
course somebody I can videotaping her
some [__] yeah
so when you get your shits transcribed
and then what are you doing are you just
kind of looking through it for like
different oh [__] yeah okay like okay
because I I basically do that with like
my notes and stuff and I'll just be like
oh that's a better way or a cleaner I
double space it
um oh [__] wow yeah yeah
and I said uh the Latino culture is
this is where I said this is where we I
wrote this by hard neighbor do it I said
uh we're a culture that believes that a
religious statue in Mexico cries real
tears of blood we believe that but we
won't believe that you and the girl at
work are just friends
and your wife is like I [__] [__]
I saw you you saw me I saw you wear on a
[__] tortilla I saw you
yeah yeah uh but I like that man I mean
oh this is what I wanted to ask you so
of course everybody like girls you know
girls funny dude structurally yeah he
can go up there and and speak for 45
minutes an hour with no with no notes
Jesus I can't do that yeah
um
what would you because everybody wants
to listen everybody wants to do this
everybody wants to have a podcast
everybody's got Instagram everybody's
got Tick Tock yeah what advice would you
give for somebody wanting to create
small pieces or you know they do things
like they're they're their own mom and
they come around the corner like what's
what's a what's an easy way of writing
or creating those things I mean I think
those those things are so like when
remember when it was Vine and you were
like man Vine is [__] weird like
those Vines yeah and they were getting
like TV deals and you were like that is
not going to work because that's just
not how it works I mean that [__] is so
different to but that is almost what I
would say is just like you know just
[__] like why Wild West just [__]
riff go and just do it's so like if you
think about if you have an hour of
content you can do on stage and 40
minutes of it sucks people will be
unhappy but on your Instagram if you
have our Tick Tock if you have a hundred
that suck and one that does big nobody's
gonna give a [__] what if you had a guy
and a girl on your on your show and when
the guy talked
and then when the girl talks you just
see like the head of a [__] coming up
and the guy goes yeah I agree with that
and it goes back down
whatever she talks
yeah and also your sister or your sister
it goes back down you know it's like a a
meter while they're talking yeah I like
that we're gonna do that next week I'm
gonna go get a fake bed again put it up
a fake and just in a suit you know I'd
like to talk to you today about the
beaches managers being destroyed but you
know there's still wonderful things to
if I'd admire out of the beach how to
monitor your water yeah uh yeah so so
yeah what would you say I'm sorry I
interrupted you no I mean I think that
like you know I think it's like
I think I mean again like I'm just I put
up clips and sometimes I'll do character
stuff but specificity with that [__]
like when you're saying like someone is
someone's mom or something like that it
is specifics there's stuff where
I I almost think I would imagine you
feel like this a little bit too where
you're just like my mind doesn't
necessarily work in that like shorter
form way but when people do impressions
of their family like that was the advice
I got when I first started doing
stand-up was like just talk about my
dad's like a weirdo so they were just
like talk about your dad you know my dad
has a weird ass accent he it like half
American half English but it sounds
South African and that was just like and
then I just started doing stand-up with
that and people really relate to that
sort of [__] so I'd be like interact
with your family member you create your
own little world like we think of Kyle
Dunnigan yes who like crushes that [__]
have you seen Kyle Dunnigan no he has a
podcast yeah what does he use like a
face he uses he uses face filters and so
he does Impressions and stuff but it's
like he now I mean he basically has
created [__] more entertaining than than
like TV he doesn't need TV
he's like his Instagram his social media
he makes TV shows on YouTube essentially
can I show guild yeah him doing uh Alec
Baldwin oh man he does Baldwin he does
Trump he does Bill Maher yo this
[__] he does Caitlyn Jenner dude
he's a he's a Crusher
great stand-up too but this stuff is the
stuff where like check this out people
freak out
thank you all for the for the well
wishes I've received
saying how shocked they are that
the me and not
situation
a beautiful condolences
about the loss of my good friend
cinematographer Hannah Montana she was
my friend she's my friend
I'm not an armor a girl who I don't even
remember you chicken [__] over a hundred
40 pounds
what excuse me
that's hilarious
Town known as Buffington Massachusetts
and this is what he actually looks like
oh geez
excuse me excuse me excuse me
cucumber cucumber
I want you to go to any other room
count to a
bit hi
but it's all face filter yeah so he just
does that with like tons of characters
and I'll be I mean you know how it is on
so like you scroll through Instagram
you're like kind of like what you know
you're short your attention is short you
come to a Kyle Dunnigan video and you're
like I'm gonna turn the volume on I'm
gonna watch it but they win you over
like yeah right at the right off the bat
like when you guys are yeah good you
capture it right away you're like I
gotta watch like well then with him you
know you know if he puts out something
yeah you will go on and give it a shot
but I hadn't seen him and then you know
like when I watch you guys it's it's
you're already in because it's not
somebody floundering until they [__]
land on something you know yeah no I
think like that's a part of it too you
know it's like you got to make decisions
I mean and lot of way it is like similar
to stand up in in ways where it's like
or like any comedy where it's like
you've kind of got to be decisive and
commit yeah and you know are you an only
child no well I got a 12 older brother
is 12 years older
so there's like that's a fine lifetime
yeah it was because you know when you're
12 years older and you know babies there
he could have [__] hid you or [__]
hungry upside down I think he did yeah
yeah and you know they're like hey don't
don't you know don't be mean to your
brother that [__] [__] him he's not
even a year old [__] he's not gonna
[__] remember this you also don't
have the thing where you like grow up
and you're like we wrestle and you know
what I mean when I was six he was 18 he
was like [__] smoking weed out of a
tin can and like you know like so yeah
they spin you around how many brothers I
had five older sisters oh wow that is
great they spin you around your [__]
shoulders out of his sock in your
[__] 11 years old
my shoulders [__] it right yeah [__]
bones all is like a [__] chicken you
just take it and it goes out of the
[__] piece yeah it's supposed to this
is supposed to be in there forever
like I'd go out there and play rough
with the boys around my block yeah
neighbors and they were in high school
and we were just in elementary school
and we go out there and play they treat
us like [__] they they beat [__] out if
you go back to your my mom if you went
back to your mom and showed that you
were hurt
you know I wanted to play you go out
there do it again don't come crying home
right now she she and she hated the guys
for hurting me but she didn't want me to
be a little [__] lala either you know
stay out there play
What's This is this is my first question
that I've asked on this show
what's the hardest you've ever been hit
in the nuts oh [__]
what's that I mean I'm gonna tell you I
never played soccer yeah
and I didn't do this to anybody you know
sometimes when you when two guys meet at
the ball oh yeah the ball goes straight
in the air yeah and then both guys back
up
waiting for it to come down the double
and they're gonna kick it so I
went to kick the ball but I wasn't a
soccer player and I missed and kicked
this dude in the nuts so you hit the
balls I'll tell you I'll hit the ball
when I got I missed the ball and kicked
him in the nuts and he never came back
to school oh my God [__] he [__] he
[__] call that [__] ambulance you
gotta you're retired I've never seen him
again that was [__] 1974. he just
became a black hole and made no children
that ended the lineage he'd grab this
dick
and rolled over to his right and I left
a beam of light they [__] just went
to the sky they brought the paramedics
onto the field is this true
I can't remember I didn't hit the ball
at all so it's a it's a young leg
kicking upward
that is because you're waiting for it
yeah I mean it could have been me but I
went like that and missed them oops
kicked the camera's balls
and hit him yeah
man so that's the hardest you've kicked
someone in the ball uh we're playing
baseball San Fernando High in the winter
which I didn't like in the winter and we
had a winter league game and it was
drizzling and we're all warming up but
it's drizzling yeah and we're like are
we gonna [__] play it's [__]
drizzling like it's soft drizzle you can
still play but we're we're waiting for
we're waiting for the coach to go hey
it's [__] drizzling or raining yeah
and we go coach it's raining here this
is [__] drizzling we're gonna take
infield the other team is warming up
they're going to take info we'll figure
it out so
I played third base
and they would make you throw it to a
second and then second would throw it to
First and first will throw it to third
to my friend Andy who has still I'm
still friends with this [__]
week my arm [__]
so he throws it and remember it's wet
yeah so it hits the grass in front of me
on like a rock in the lake it speeds up
so I first of all I see him throw it he
had this weird-ass arm and I the way he
threw it I said oh [__] that's not gonna
that's not gonna make it on the Fly and
if it hit the dirt I would have been all
right but it hit the grass and then
gained like
to almost like 1500 miles an hour oh my
God the the and I didn't even really see
it I saw it he felt it before it hit the
grass and it just slicked off because it
was grass yeah yeah and it [__] hit
me
how old
damn right
and you know how they had the foam
around the cup yeah the foam bruised
around my nuts I had one of these Vicks
like it looked like a little big slaws
around my nuts and it it when I took the
cup off I was looking at it and those
guys were like let me see and they
[__] grabbed it and it cracked a cup
they they I still remember them laughing
right now they left they left for
[__] half an hour I was down I mean
did the game get played no [__] no so
the whole thing was for nothing you just
went to the field to get your cup
cracked and your nuts broke and they're
like guys We're not gonna play it's
raining like George needs an ambulance
how about that you I would say I don't
know I always remember I I don't think
the hardest I've ever kicked someone in
the nuts no no no no no hit the hardest
hit was I used to go in high school as
well go watch uh football at my buddy's
place and he had like four younger
siblings and
somehow it got to the thing where they
like one of like his little sister was
realized that we did find you know the
thing where you you don't want to let
the kid know it's funny but the kids
realize that it was funny to try to kick
people in the nuts and it was during the
Packer game and I was standing there
because we got like an interception or
something and was and this this little
girl been like trying to kick balls all
day and first I just wasn't expecting it
and was just standing there and she just
[__] houdini'd right behind me so I
didn't see her in front of me so behind
me also a kick and really just full
contact both and it you know there's
there's a few things that happen when
you get kicked in the nuts one where you
sometimes you go I got a minute to like
get myself into triage before like the
belly feels pregnant or so you know what
I mean and then there's somewhere where
you get away with it and you're like
holy [__] I don't know how that didn't
this was this was pain right away and
illness and I had nowhere to go and it
was a dropper and I went right down and
it was like a 30 minute recovery
because normally it'll be 15. this is
like 30 of like it takes a [__] long
time you're losing you're all right man
but normally you have a minute to go
like where do I want to die yeah yeah
you know and you can find like a couple
you can put some pillows together and
drop but I was like done
so yeah 30 minutes so you never you so
you were celebrating all of a sudden you
feel over it I was like I don't I don't
know what the [__] phone from behind
this brutal behind no it's like the
Houdini punch that's what killed him he
wasn't ready for like a sniper yeah
never what let's go to the parking lot
Sports let's go play cats fights
all the years fighting you've never been
there but never been hit uh nothing not
that I can remember so it could have
been that devastating if not even in
nothing
you know I lucky guy have you ever have
you ever you know what the sensation is
you've hit your yeah you've whacked your
balls yeah but I mean when he says you
know one of the heart is I there hasn't
been anything you know I didn't I
haven't rolled over I haven't fallen
down in the ground nothing nothing in
pain you're pure that's what we call
people he's you've gone pure you know
like a versatility you try to go clear
yeah you've gone pure
yeah I've never you've gone pure yeah
um what do you make of the podcast
phenomenon like when do they come to you
and say you want to do this podcast
thing well basically like I met Dave who
kind of had the idea for the show and he
was gonna like rotate Comedians and we
just had like good [__] right away and I
think partially because you know it's a
pain in the ass to book comedians so
he's just like lets you and I do it and
um
and this was
you know this was like eight years ago
and so like and our so our podcast kind
of like exploded because it's
entertaining but also it was not a
saturated Market you know yeah so
um so we kind of for a while we were
just like you know we just had a lot
going on with it
um and then like everything else I mean
it's like you know you people are gonna
start doing the same [__] eventually and
so now podcasting is a thing where
you know it's a very saturated thing
like a lot like pretty much everybody
does a podcast most like when Obama and
Bruce Springsteen were doing a podcast I
was like this is some [__] this is
what the [__] leave a piece uh but
you know I mean it's just like anything
else it's like you got it look if this
is entertainment so you got to compete
you got to be like as good as you can be
you kind of almost would rather have to
like stay Sharp versus like rest on your
laurels there's a lot of podcasts that
like once they hit
you know they do start to kind of suck a
little bit more because people are like
yeah whatever we got the ad money and do
people do you think people stay loyal
like they would to a um to a television
show yeah that they routinely watch it
but I think like a TV show too you
probably lose you know when you get to
season four or five some people are just
like yeah I'm kind of used to it but
then you have the the core audience
who's like I [__] love it right and
and podcasts give you the ability to
have like that core audience and I think
like we're really lucky to have that if
you can get that and you get like you
know like for you it's like an extension
for you it's like this is just I mean
it's a much different way to connect
with your fans but you already have you
know you already have fans this is just
the diff for me it's like this is what
gave me fans you know which is um for me
which was like [__] crazy because I
like I said I kind of like was like that
ship of sale so for you you're you're
your freedom is you're bringing people
in I could lose I could lose people by
talking yeah and I and I think like by
you know by stand up too it's like
you know like I try to convert my
podcast fans into stand-up fans right
you know yeah that's the natural yeah
you don't drink beer do you uh I'm on a
dry January otherwise I would drink
what's [__] dry January [__]
I don't drink during I drink I have a
soaking December so I get shit-faced
every night of December oh you do and
then January would that take the place
of Lent but I mean I'll have one no no
not if you've been dry the whole time
that's [__] comedy
see how smooth that was though yeah it's
like a peer pressure
if this was a [__] thing
killing the nuts
up it's making his first appearance hey
next week I'm gonna bring a [__]
dildo in here I gotta think I got one at
home
right
I think I think I think I read I have
one
um
yeah man I mean
Gil this was all guilt I mean I'm
talking about Guild
so Gil was this [__] incredible
detective this is the thing is like I've
mentioned it before but I'm not sure how
what you think you know like you become
like a certain age
and how old are you so how old were you
when you I was 31 when I started working
and when you asked you to retire uh 60.
they didn't ask me I I just 60. they
wanted me to stay I didn't oh you didn't
want oh yeah I didn't during that time
they were asking me to be a yes man and
I'm not a yes man well then so I hey I'm
at the top of my game things are going
good I'll just leave and I won't go all
bitter you know you think that's how
they ask you do you think that's how
they get people to retire no they it was
very specific they wanted
two things going on [__] around on a
computer you know dirty joke sex [__]
like that okay you sent them to me or if
I see you doing I'm supposed to rat you
out computer police has policy I
understand so I told my guys okay look
don't send that [__] to me because if
they they monitor and if I get caught
I'm gonna get spanked real hard you're
gonna get spanked but I'm gonna get
spanked even harder because I'm I'm your
supervisor don't do it and I'm telling
you right now I'm not going to turn you
in I won't do it
if it's that good I'm not a prude send
it to my personal computer at all right
you know I I so
that's one thing because that's policy
the real reason I left was because
my boss my captain at that time said the
executives want us to come up with a new
scheduling pattern I've never said this
publicly no no uh so I said you know
they want us to work zero overtime
and I said and I was the only I was a
lieutenant so there's six lieutenants up
there and a captain I'm the only one
that has ever worked murders before
these guys don't come out with your
hands up and so oh [__] never mind I
did I just said I mean do it but we
won't be here for it promise that's an
impossible task we are a reactionary
Force yeah we go out we don't schedule
murders whenever they go that's we I
said so you got a guy that's been
working all day and he gets a murder so
he goes out to Warriors murder then what
does he do tell the families hey excuse
me my eight hours are up I gotta go home
we'll be back tomorrow yeah crazy that's
a [__] [__] and and he said the
first time I said what are you gonna do
when that happens he says first time
somebody tries that next morning that we
rolled up they'll be gone and I said you
can't do that you know it's you can't do
that you won't do that and at the end of
the meeting he says that if there's
anybody in the staff that can't go along
with the program they can be rolled up
as well you know we'll just find a new
home for them
yikes he didn't realize you know he
didn't have the juice car to get me
rolled up but I didn't feel like banging
heads with anybody man this job has been
good to me having to have you know I'm
good I know what I am so I said okay you
know it's time for me to leave
and I told the sheriff and the
undersheriff it's a big decision though
man you make it sound like you know I
knew it was time for me to leave but
that [__] 30 years yeah yeah I didn't
want to bang Ed so it was and I left did
you cry no I didn't cry I was I missed
it I ran into the sheriff I'm saying I'm
saying because I would [__] miss it
man yeah oh [__] yeah three years I told
the sheriff six months after I was on
credit they replaced my knee and I'm on
crutches as soon as hey
so uh what are you doing retiree and I
said I said I'm I'm doing you know I'm
making it I said but make no mistakes
about it I ain't gonna [__] you I
missed the job I missed the guys that I
was working with their profession I
missed the rollouts or anymore and I
missed talking to you I miss those
pictures of [__] Mexicans with
[__] 30 kids around them giving young
kids a ray of hope there's more to
police yeah he said come on back it says
get your anything here he says come on
back I said no I left for the right
reasons going back
is not what I need to do I'm not a yes
man you need yes people and I wasn't a
yes man so I think the worst [__]
thing to be is a [__] yes man yeah so
I couldn't just go along and yeah I mean
you get like I'm sure like you deal with
that in in our business too you know
like I'm sure you've run into that [__]
but the podcast gives you a freedom of
dude it's the game changer that's what I
liked about stand-up because I was doing
stand up before podcast it was like you
know right like when you're writing [__]
you got to send it to someone and
they're like yeah like someone who
doesn't know comedy who's like I don't
like this and that and you're just like
yeah that's your job is not to tell me
jokes you can like tell me other [__]
but to be like I don't like a joke or
something like that stand up you
literally get to find out if it's funny
you know and you do it a few times if it
sucks it sucks if it murders you keep
working on it no not there is murder
there's nothing better
than humor to make people feel good and
get them engaged and they look if it's
funny to listen to you because they want
to hear more well it's also on the other
end to be like eliciting that is like
truly just one of those I mean you just
get addicted so quick I remember being
like seven years old and like doing a
play in like grade school and getting a
laugh and that like stuck with me for
the rest of my life and being like that
feeling is very good you know the other
night I did uh they called it uh wine
and crime crime and wine wine and crack
and it was at a winery
and so I showed a video and then it's
questioned and answers after people from
the wine club there and it and it sold
out you know uh
in two days
small venue one up there and talked
listen first of all
and venue
I think I sound like jumbo shrimp right
yeah right because venue means big I
think in France oh I don't know and so
so it's like a small bit it's a small
building small
place that was being held yes yeah and
so we did it and they said and my wife
was there
they gave us uh an Airbnb oh [__] a
couple of couples took uh six of us went
is it better like when you've been
married 51 years and you go to a B and B
with your wife and know that you don't
have to [__] from pressure that night
like when I was married and we go to a
place and my wife would be like this
place is beautiful I don't know what
that code is code I think I'm gonna have
to get this [__] let's go
no I'd be I'd look to get the shits yeah
I would look at that [__] Yelp I
don't gotta [__] this place yeah yeah
you could
I'll eat the trash we're 180 degrees
apart I look forward to that [__] all
right that's [__] crazy
I hit it did you have to hit it in the
the air no we had two other couples with
us well it's not a game
yeah
yeah get your balls hit finally put
[__] back around yeah the reach
around the reach under
so
I'm up there talking question and answer
period three different people said how
come you're not doing stand-up you stand
up you ought to do and I right in front
of my wife said hey I know about three
people were Rudy Moreno no really
Barcena Carlos Mencia and I just said no
I was asked about that one time I said I
thought my wife said she didn't want me
up here and she didn't want me doing
stand-up you know so why did she say
that and you said that to the people yes
that's listen man come on all right I'm
coming I'm doing hey my [__] wife
didn't want me to do it
her [__] got her that little [__]
little [__] munchkin right there now
[__] Dunkin Donuts because she heard
that I I wasn't afraid she heard it
because I wasn't afraid to say it in
public she's the one to do and my friend
that is your first [__] step down the
yellow brick comedy road yeah when your
wife is in there and you're not afraid
to say my wife doesn't want me to do it
then that's almost you're jumping off
point yeah
yeah and you're getting [__] laughs
and what you're doing is it's almost
like a [__] like Pac-Man you're just
collecting laughs collecting [__]
energy and you're talking about what you
it's off of what you know you know yeah
it was it was nice it was it was we can
never finish the story but they keep
doing [__] interrupted sorry no no no
so so you went up there what did you say
though that you went up there it was
whining and crying what was your topic a
Zinfandel and a [__] double murder
something
with any likes yeah like uh
yeah most everybody there had already
seen the documentary they all know what
it's so I showed them a different if
there was one person in there I said I
didn't say [__] you then the night what
then I watched churches here for why
video I introduced myself I showed this
video that talks All About The Night
Stalker explains everything okay once
that's done and then he's already doing
multimedia yeah right opening up
question and answers
and I got one of the you say did you say
like this uh I'm gonna open it up the
question answers but first nine inches
flaccid yeah and you [__] take off
you start with yourself start with your
bed again some lady asked why do so many
women follow these serial killers like
that and my initial response was hey I'm
not Dr Phil different show you ask him I
don't know why that's the psychological
you should say I'm Dr full full
is that what you say they laughed at
that yeah and you know people that there
was a lot of there was a few things
people were laughing at but you know
your body language is uh you're you're
not into it no no in your arms right now
it's because it's comfortable it's a
little cool in here I left my I love
covering hard nipples
Diamond Cutters all right [__]
desserts yeah so it was uh it was a good
night and I and but but no no no I mean
listen if I was let's say if we were
detectives yes let's say he and I are
detectives all right here we go he knows
from Comedy and I would because of the
same thing if you say yeah it was a
great night there's a whole [__] ton
of [__] that we're not hearing right yes
all right well hey let me know what
detail we're detail people well let me
say this I'm the suspect you two are the
cops I'm gonna tell you right now [__]
you I don't want to talk with my
attorney I ain't got to tell you [__] I
mean yeah you could you could lawyer up
but we just want to know a couple guys
talking over here yeah I mean uh-uh but
but did you did you have a uh set time
or here's this because I was never
really that comfortable on stage so
neither was Letterman they said
Letterman would say how much time are
you doing he goes well I got 20 minutes
I could do 20 I could do it in 40
minutes or I could do it in 20 minutes
right she said I remember would say I
only have 20 minutes you want me to do
it in 40.
or do you want me to do it in 20. it's
the same 20. but I can extend it to 40.
and take longer pauses or 20. yeah you
tell me I only have 20. you want it to
be 30 I can make it 30. I can't make it
over 40. it's only It could only go it
only goes 40. so I when I would get up I
would be like get me the [__] out of
here like they would say do 15 hey you
did 12. did I I thought oh also those
words when you're ramping through the
material and you're going [__] I need 12
and I'm at seven I'm almost done I'm
almost done hey what do you do yeah yeah
so you're pretty question and answer
yeah this was how easy because it was
all q a all on something that I'm an
expert that I know about so it was uh I
need to get do you have set do you have
set lines that you might say no I just
go up there whatever of them you know
last time I did Vegas they said uh 45 45
minutes and this is is that a lot of
time too it's a lot to me
no they said what are you doing there
you're doing like similar things or just
like another kind of q a deal this was
no the this one they wanted me to talk
about uh my career and where I went and
then that develops and then once you get
into homicides then you get to the knife
which is kind of which would be like
your headlining material exactly right
yeah so then you carry it on with that I
said oh okay and the night before I was
having some wine and some dinner and
they said so what are you going to talk
about tomorrow
and I said I have no idea
yeah right I'll find out tomorrow
morning when I'm there and up on stage
and so that's what I did Jesus and then
they have a it's it's a professionally
done thing and they got a clock and he
sponsors it I think they have a clock
right there and you can watch see how
much time he got and I said okay well
Hey listen this is great but I've got
time for maybe one two more questions
is it time for a e to change its network
name skill oh [__] I don't arts and
entertainment and it's all just murder
and yeah that's all it is now yeah M um
MCS yeah yeah
but it was our it was arts and
everything but then they have the
evening surprise back in the day yeah
yeah I remember that even at the Improv
yeah it was out of off brand but
yeah there's still Arts Center still
Arts I remember my English mother used
to love a e that's how I knew it was
like a weird Network
because it was like what would you watch
why don't you think of antique Roadhouse
love I this is what I remember growing
up was Sunday nights she would watch PBS
Agatha Christie murder shows and I knew
Sunday night [__] sucks that's the
whitest woman in the world dude as well
and it's all white if it was like quarro
and like uh have a black person walking
yeah get the [__] out
[Laughter]
cut that [__] out
we were doing good for the first half
hour and then Placido [__] Domingo
[__] walked out [__] everybody
the whitest [__] but it was also what
you could rely on I hated it though I
would like sit there and I'll be on the
one TV with cable one of these [__]
don't stop when she [__] yeah I
should be happy because I would just be
like is it over like my catchphrase like
is it over how could it feels like it's
over how come time goes by so fast now
and when you're sitting next to watch
Lauren's walk with my grandparents oh my
God damn like that's how you would
extend your life to make your life feel
160 years when Arthur Duncan would
[__] come out and start dancing with
my grandma would say that they're
musical okay no George
Lawrence well that was my dad one of my
dad's favorite shows my grandmother
wanted to go I think they did at the
Palladium I go Grandma goes I gotta go
joy where do you think they filmed that
I think they filmed by the New Zealand
foreign
Hollywood Palladium
I made it sound like like you had to get
there by [__] shuttle the space
shuttle
so so so
is it so that the wine and did you get
paid no this one I did uh the guy that
told me about coming to call up George
Lopez would he put it on the radio the
guy that called me and said hey did you
put it out of the way no you did
I just heard better than nothing I heard
I heard on the radio George Lopez just
had him but no guilt Korea have him give
me a call the first time you started
looking for me when I called you and
left you a message yes okay well that
guy was a lead guitar player in a band I
used to play with we were kids and that
band was named the right Foods the
righteous rhythms the the righteous
Earth okay and so not the not the the
t-h-w can I tell you a story you can
tell me a story intro intros are always
the best right yeah so I was doing Trump
29 had a casino out there this was years
ago
and there's a little guy with a suit he
goes hi I'm the announcer I'd like to
just get a bit of an introduction from
you gentlemen it would be great I'd do
the intros myself
and uh he got he got Lowell Sanders he
says they do the whole thing
gotta get some microphone
Trump 29 Casino proudly welcomes George
Lopez
and then we could hear clapping hit back
up
but first please welcome an Entertainer
who has worked with such luminaries as
Aretha Franklin
Gladys Knight and the Pips and Luther
Vandross
please welcome Lowell Thomas it's
Sanders right so he goes Lowell Thomas
and Logan Sanders [__]
hello Thomas Sanders [__] Thomas
Sanders and he [__] walked out you
could hear it I record the shows and you
could hear him in the background Lowell
Thomas Sanders Sanders the whole
professional air
I I was [__] on the floor [__]
dying yeah because of his you know
they're Vandross
the Pips I've rehearsed it all day uh
LOL Thomas said Robert Sanders Sanders
[__]
[__] in the back yeah so so so
yeah the not the the Right double e
that's from you yeah I was gonna say
that's mine so
his kid Richard Jr now drives uh he's
got his own limo service
uh Tour de Vino he's got three limos and
he does wine tours in the Temecula
Valley he had asked me a couple years
ago if I would consider doing something
for him he said really make him look
good and I said I'd love to Son but I'm
under contract with Netflix at the time
and I couldn't talk about the nightstalk
wow [__] Diamond Jim Brady over here
yeah I love your son but uh I'm spoken
for him to push him in the chest it's a
v Netflix
excuse me the Netflix back up if you've
heard of it Aaron you're lucky you're on
the other side check this out of this
[__] here can you put this cigarette
away put it out in your own hand God
damn it open your mouth ashtray
get over here
this dude's got it man
You Got The Magic Eye Hoyt so his son
drives a tour I said Okay a couple years
the contract's over so now I said hey I
can do this for you now son and just as
a favor you know that's what I'm doing
so
but do you think
can I say would it's not a favor really
uh no because you have to drive there
you're giving them your time it's a
something that don't ever give away what
you do don't ever do for free what you
give away but you love it yeah I did and
I truly did Temecula okay
that's pretty far three hours out there
your [__] Radio starts kind of did it
once for them now as a result
they want they want me to do another one
oh my God where are we but they realize
the next one's not for free that idea it
filled him up so the next one will be
here and he's telling me hey everybody
in the valley all the wine they're
saying hey
yeah so now they they all want a piece
of the action and he says and they all
know it's not free
so there may be something I have
showcase yeah I have yet to speak some
place are you wearing a scarf we're
right enough come on next time I'm just
a guy like an aleisterial tool over here
Agatha Christie look I'm your guy oh I
get a beret a scarf the whole thing
every time I've spoken publicly and no
matter how bored you can stay in the
room that's right I still get hey I'll
pick up a job from where I'm at to go
someplace else have you ever considered
having an agent uh yes but it hasn't got
that business I I I I baked I would I
would say I'd beg to differ on that yeah
I think if you had an agent so what they
would do is they know what's going on in
all of these situations and they agency
put out stuff to the agents and if they
have you they plug you in if they don't
know you you don't get plugged in yep as
well as like we were saying before like
crime and wine I mean or like crime and
Jet if you're like if that's your
jumping off point that subject matter is
as weird as it is like like we were
saying again when we walked in everyone
was dead yeah it's like murder mystery
dinners yeah you know I used to do in
Boston murder mystery boat cruises where
we'd have to dress up like characters
and it was like the lowest red [__] ever
but I'm telling you P like that if you
had a real version I would either be the
hippie or like the flamboyant actor guy
but I was mostly the hippie which was
easy hey what's going on guys yeah I got
shot at one point so I was like man I
don't know where he is Manny I don't
remember what he looked like man yeah
yeah 100 bucks and we'd go out and the
Boston Harbor for three hours and these
people would get like throw up on the
boat [__] up
yeah like I was like I don't think
they're trying to really solve these
crimes
you'd have some like hammered woman is
like I think it's all actually a bunch
of [__] woodstocks I'd be like no
man like I need you to get out of my way
I gotta go back oh my God that's [__]
hilarious yeah that's [__] hilarious
yeah it was the weirdest but that's like
but that's what that but but also people
getting [__] up yeah and welcome to
his open bar oh my God the hall in
Boston it's all like how do we cover for
like local alcoholism like that was
certainly like they were they were like
you get food and you get to solve a
mystery of people like and all the
whiskey we can drink and that was the
mystery was where did all the [__]
booze go in these people if you ever
thought of of the of a boat [__]
Halloween candy from your first [__]
Halloween come out of you like yeah
there's something about the water and
about having to drop it's an epic hack
bar yeah
I ate dice yeah yeah what yeah
it's a baby
we went on a trip to Hawaii and I
thought my brother-in-law's wife was
gonna kill me because he gets seasick we
got out there and a little catamaran and
he started getting sick and the more
cigarette got the more I laughed and
then the captain says get him on the
other side of the boat and they started
moving to win it the wrong way [__]
vomit hit the captain get that
[__] out of the way then they
threw anchor and the captain told my
brother-in-law [__] get in the
water and look at the land he says it'll
calm me down and that'll make you feel
good he got in the water he started
puking in the water I said [__]
everybody back in the boat he's jumping
for sharks oh yeah oh yeah there's no
sharks like look I'm a little hungry I
mean how can he barf I'd rather fish I
couldn't stop laughing and I thought of
the funniest thing in the world she
wanted to kill me and as soon as we got
back in land it was okay
man I I used to get like super seasick
and that's that will stick with you how
did you get that gig out there doing
doing a [__] Woodstock out there in
the middle that was literally like in
Boston because I went to school for
acting and nobody would audition for
[__] and they were like local casting
agencies and so I just started like
submitting myself and I would get called
in for the weirdest [__] like never like
sometimes commercials that would be like
you know every now and then it'd be like
a movie but you know you'd never have a
shot but I would get like the weirdest
[__] and this was one of them this dude
was auditioning people for this thing
and like I said I was in college and it
was a hundred bucks a Saturday which was
like you know decent and so I just I
don't know I just did improv in the
audition and the dude just liked me and
then he just invited me on and then
every Saturday night I'd go out in the
harbor for three [__] hours and just
like 100 bucks yeah and just be like no
man I don't know what it was yeah but
like yeah but it was like I mean yeah
you weren't afraid of
you weren't afraid of it so you weren't
afraid to do it to go out there and do
it behind the camera maybe maybe the
first maybe the first couple times like
where you kind of you know the unknown
is like scary but you know it is like
you
I mean I feel that even now obviously
way more but you know you never know
really what to expect a lot of [__] I
was never really
and I would even say now still not
entire I mean I'm comfortable up there
but oh man if it doesn't if it doesn't
fit what I'm used to I'm not very good
outside but don't you think that like
because I'll feel like sometimes like
like I'm going out this weekend and I
I've had two and a half months at home
and I'm like and I just recorded my
special like I released it in like
December oh tell everybody what's your
specialty it's called England weed and
the rest it's actually on the all things
comedy YouTube page oh great so um you
can just go to my website which is
garethrenals.com there's a special link
um and it's it's great everybody
um that's awesome but but so I've had
two and a half months at home and even
like a weekend like I'll you'll stand in
the back and you'll be like I don't know
what it's gonna be like I feel that
still but then you I would imagine you
get up there and you go pretty soon once
you get your first laugh you're like all
right I know what I'm doing yeah yeah no
no I know if it's if it's coming to see
me but like outside or anything I was
never that comfortable and what and
you're in stand-up situations yeah
really yeah because see I mean I feel
like you're like amazing at it so I
would imagine that like
one time I did the the [__] Yakima
State Fair it's like three grand in the
afternoon there was nobody there it's
like seven people we used to do and at
the minute I said we're still gonna do
the show and I said the guy says you
ready
oh man I said
I had to do an hour seven people what
the [__] that is brutal the guy goes no
no but go out there and your voice will
bring them to you remember I I was not
comfortable outside when is this this
was in the [__] 80s okay [__] so this
is like so
this is how bad it was nobody's laughing
nobody knows me I'm out there in this
place for like 1507 people out there
and I look over and there's a [__]
clown on a on a tricycle with his big
feet on the outside and he's doing the
horn
and he's got [__] [__] coming out of
his hair and I look at him and remember
I'm so [__] green I look at him I go
hey man how about a little professional
courtesy
and then 10 minutes later I said where's
that [__] clown at yeah did you want
to work together
oh man yeah I mean those situations when
you are like you know when you're [__]
you know when you're beat there are ones
where you just go it's over I did kids
birthday parties for like probably seven
years in L.A and that makes you so
conditioned to bombing
that like I can but what did you do at a
kid's birthday party I would not stand
up well in a way my boss would always be
like it's like stand up and I'd be like
man no it's not it's I'm in like a
Spider-Man outfit
um
but it's an hour
and you had to keep the attention of
children which sometimes like Saturday
late show feels like you're trying to
keep the attention to children to some
extent oh yeah and so I would basically
roll up I would find the birthday kid do
some like stupid bits then do a magic
trick get them right out of the gate
then a game then another magic trick
then another game like a limbo or like
musical hula hoops and then the closer
was balloon animals and balloon animals
were the best because you knew it would
be like 15 to 20 minutes
your kids are going to be engaged in
that and you can milk it like like we
were saying like if you feel like [__]
I'm going through this too fast I can
make balloon animals for a half hour I
would temper it like if I if I had 10
minutes because I ran late I just make
every kid a sword by being like I can
make you a dog a cat a sword or a car
and they'd be like sure
but then if I see that girl that's a
good one but then if I'm like 30 minutes
left I would be like I make poodles I
make extravagant poop you know I'd be
like pitching the hard [__] yeah so that
I could sit there and like milk the time
but it was like you know there are times
where you know what as long as I've been
doing [__] stand-up I never
considered that like if somebody go do
you want to talk about this you want to
talk about it or the Earth yeah
yeah we could do Algebra we could talk
about the Earth yeah you could be like
well look we're talking about Earth we
can talk about banging doggy style we
could talk about you know
but so that was what I would do and then
so I would be like
um and that was like true Lonely Island
bombing where it was you again in a
strange world I didn't know anybody and
yeah you'd Bob kids and kids like can
[__] cut you like murder you so bad
Gil shows up like they can cut you down
so quickly I'll find them you better
what are they say what do they say like
well
well there's that first of all there's
like not getting their attention which
is like brutal you know and they're like
he sucks this is stupid that's death but
the worst the worst would be I could see
his face under the mask and then you'd
be like [__] this is like gonna be a
struggle if kids are trying to [__]
bust you on being fake under there you
are it's it's a nightmare like I
remember right like remember you did it
as a kid you tried to see the dude's
face in like Chuck E cheese and stuff
like a kid would be like I saw him I saw
his face and you'd be Scooby-Doo like
look shut the [__] this is the wrong
mystery like that they would do that
yeah you see a kid back there in a
bucket challenge yeah you see like a
stone dude like me he's like God damn it
I shouldn't say this for all the kids
out there that believe it's Santa Claus
but I've done Santa Claus a bunch of
times and I can remember doing Santa
Claus in the body and some little kid
comes up he said you're not the real
Santa Claus I can tell it's a fake beard
and he reaches and he starts to pull my
beard you and I just smacked his hand
and went here move on and he goes
he gave me the finger and the
grandfather he says come on come on
let's go you probably started it and
walked him away he probably started with
Santa Claus
Santa's a good man you're a little [__]
that's right he knew well you'd when I
would do Santa you'd get like so
conditioned to like those hands might be
coming that you would be like you know
you would be like Bruce Lee I know but
there was a good looking lady with big
dick times over here so my cops are
crazy
what does he say in a sec
yeah but that would be you're into the
[__] lightning round can you feel
that yeah
so so they would do that they would be
like yeah that would be the word that
was death when a kid or a kid would see
your watch or a Spider-Man they'd see
your skin but I'd be like I'm Peter
Parker but that argument would never
work right you lose you lose them and
there's like
an hour of that [__] we're halfway
through you've lost control which didn't
happen a lot but when it did you were
like oh man this [__] this time's
going backwards right now and like I
would go through that every now and then
and like but in the same way that we're
talking about like back a club like
anxiety I would before I go into a party
I'd be sitting in my car and I'd be
sizing them up and be like oh these are
like little [__] you know you'd want
like a five six seven year old sometimes
you get like one and you'd be like what
the [__] are you what is your
expectation for me to do with this baby
the good looking mother well that would
happen too we're like
you get fetishized by my mother's a
little bit like mothers that have like
Spider-Man fantasies or something you
know and you'd be like this is kind of
like an easy guilt
we could work this yeah
there was uh well for Mayans for mine's
50 fifth birthday party
and had a bowling uh thing in
Monroeville montro Monrovia yeah there's
that little quaint bowling out like
three lanes running the whole thing out
and then Ariel came with a red hair and
the biggest [__] at that you've ever oh
my God natural
seashell Beauty shell bra oh everybody's
bowling and all the guys are over here
like dude you're up yeah I don't ball
anymore I retired it's almost like
throwing a pebble in the water every
little move is just ripples effective
people like oh we're trying to see that
little bucket pepperoni slice
any pepperoni slices we're trying I
think we think so it might be just her
hair
but I mean all the fathers I mean I've
never seen anything like it yeah almost
like you hire an aerial but then you you
don't see her you go oh you're a picture
probably she looks good and when she got
there you're just like holy [__] yeah
this is she worked this Pyramid Rhino at
night
and she's not up there for her health
guys she's trying to get rid of that
tail give her some money I want to help
set your fat ass back down over there
I love the mermaid
yeah I would but I would like you know I
would like get that where it would be
like you'd show up and there'd be like a
smoking hot like you'd be a prince or a
princess and you'd be like Jesus I'm in
love with this princess you know they'd
always be professional and they'd be
like all right Spiderman with a little
Wessel right there yeah
I made some
webbed in here pardon me I've webbed
may I use the inside bathroom I seem to
have gotten some webbing on the outfit
I think I could stick to the building if
I tried
he's not holding on you know well and
you'd show I would show up like a
[__] [__] hilarious I would show
up in like Spandex and I'm like me so
it's like Spiderman would be jacked so
kids would be like well what was the
outfit for was it a real Spider-Man
outfit well I mean like was it a one
piece or I think one piece nylon but you
know skin tight so now they have it
where you could have muscles and all
that [__] yeah it's different now yeah
and and but then it was just like for me
it was just like look if you're like
[__] you know you've been drinking a
lot of booze you're gonna show up
looking like are you saying that I would
make a good Spider-Man yeah no you'd
make a great one he could be perfect
they would be like Spider-Man has love
handles and you're like oh my God enough
already you know or and you couldn't see
your dick Spiderman has a love handles
you could totally see your dick and that
would be a thing where you'd be like
this is like the most awkward [__] like
a little Baskin-Robbin spoon background
[Music]
a little spoon right there okay you like
to do your [__] signal lights off
Buzz Lightyear what do you expect I'm
trying to get to my home planet
I need them and I keep all my important
doctors down there
but that [__] is not performing as
people man listen people only say like
you get nervous when you go up there
there's a [__] thousand [__]
things performers do that are [__]
scarier than stand up yeah and one of
them is being a character at a [__]
kid's birthday party yeah no that is
that is like I mean the Wolves fully you
know nobody full-on and the expectation
is like if you bomb I mean it is it
sucks and it is like a bad feeling but
like when it is literally your job to
keep the attention of children as a
character and you're not man you're just
like [__] and do they ever say like you
know hey uh you know we thought it'd be
a little more exciting or some [__] yeah
there was there was definitely times
when people would you know where people
well first of all I mean you you would
have the times where you'd be like these
kids just literally want to beat the
[__] out of me right like and you'd be
like I kind of gotta like figure out how
to make that go for it and can you see
through the mask yeah for the most part
there are certain times where it would
suck like I was I was SpongeBob once and
it's like the eye holes were like like
it was like good for a horse head but
like for a human man you're like I can't
see [__] and I mean you just do feel
like Haymakers going at your belly and
your ass and you know
um but you you definitely like had a lot
of like visual issues you would have
um you know you would yeah you would
have parents just be like I felt like
you were and you'd be like I this is not
this is not great with a bigger concert
like SpongeBob I invent you have balance
issues yeah oh dude I was when you used
to be a Transformer you would be like
I'm gonna like fall at the hardest I've
ever seen my brother laugh is there was
this one called I love [__] that starts
like that it was the one and my brother
like laughs but this is like where my
brother I was like is he okay we were
actually in a bowling uh alley parking
lot because I go pick up all these
costumes from this dude and then so I'd
have them and I'd like get my work
orders and I'd be like okay so it's like
Friday night we're gonna go bowling and
I get this one and it's called The Dark
Magician and it's this Yu-gi-oh
character
and the Dark Magician is like whatever
it's got like a wizard staff and all
that [__] it's purple but the one thing
it also had was a like four foot head
piece
and so I'm telling him I'm like dude
this one is crazy and he's like let me
see I put it on and he like lost he
couldn't believe that I had to like go
in through doorways in it oh my God and
so you'd be bending over like get a
balloon and you'd just be like and you
could see a kid like you know like
you're just gavel bang a child's head
and you're like oh and you you know you
got like the four second window where
like a kid is trying to register how
upset it was you would have to go over
there quickly and be like hey all right
that's okay right they'd be like uh okay
yeah
you'd be like get on your knees to go
into the house and [__] like that and
you're just knocking kids over and they
were just like so many encumbrances
where you would just be like man you get
thrown to the Wolves yeah that's a bit
five seven times a weekend because the
guy that didn't the guy that hired you
[__] is nowhere to be around dude he
would do them but you guess he would get
like he'd be like yeah I'm gonna be
Prince eight times you know he'd have
like an easy gig whereas I'd be like man
I'm the Hulk I can't see I'm like
sweating I had I had a Darth Vader once
where I was like legitimately thought I
was gonna to die like from the heat in
The Mask I was like this is like I
probably looked like Darth Vader when
you took it off I was just like
dehydrated I looked like a raisin like
you were just dying in some of those
outfits and all those [__] costumes
are [__] they're hot as [__] hot as
[__] I can't even imagine doing it now
because even when I did it it was hot
but it's like you know like last song
like some of the summer he we didn't I
didn't get to like that and you always
had to [__] show up you couldn't like
not you couldn't no show well yeah that
was the one thing was always that like
and this it you were like there's like a
kid like that would be the one thing I
would think that would be like it would
just like it's even hungover drunk
whatever the [__] it was I would show up
because I would be like you know like
you kind of gotta do it and it would
suck
it would suck but there would be times
where you'd that
after you'd be like oh you're dying how
did I do like I need an IV and I just
did for an hour was a referee and like
Sherman Oaks somehow that shit's crazy
isn't it crazy
crazy because you got to come in like
low profile and you're like knock oh
come on in yeah oh hey our the [__]
Yu-Gi-Oh Yu-Gi-Oh [__] characters
here they'd be like Winnie the Pooh you
know they'd be like here we want you in
this living room and you'd be like
there's 18 kids and like the most
cramped little space and you should do
that like listen we never did that [__]
for growing up a [__] party we didn't
have that [__] either well my grandma
there should be a thing called I had a
party [__] what party for what Uncle
Ben's kitty land over there behind
McDonald's on on Sepulveda and they had
a drive-through and we'd go over there
and you could see it was like a small
kitty land like it was a rollercoaster
horses and things and kids had birthday
parties there I guess I'm gonna tell you
right now I can still remember being in
the car do the McDonald's drive-through
right where the car was looking directly
into Uncle Ben's Kiddieland foreign
and uh I look at my grandma said do you
think I could have my birthday party
over there and she's like for what so
all your friends could go
it's like a fair question
how old you're what like seven eight
seven I don't remember thank God the
owner [__] the kid they closed it down
by the way
so I would have to go through that every
year
I I don't think I ever had a party until
after I was a grown adult married really
yeah I never had a kitty party that's
interesting my two younger sisters did I
don't remember myself my myself and my
four older ones I don't remember ever
what is the Mexican [__] attitude
behind hey
for what yeah it's his birthday so so
[__] so what
I have no idea we're going to celebrate
everybody's [__] birthday oh man uh
yeah yeah it's kind of like
everyone's kind of signing off on it
every [__] day is New Year's Eve
uh but yeah we don't have uh I never had
a birthday party yeah
listen I I mean you know we all I never
asked any of my therapists what uh I
have a hard time opening presents really
that's because I never really got any
so I don't really know what to do or
what's how to react I got [__]
birthday presents from the [__] 2000s
I haven't opened really
they're in my house right we they just I
tell them put them in the garage and I
know that
I know that they're from people that are
significant to me
but I still don't open them that's crazy
so if someone gives you a gift do you
you know what just say put it in a
[__] box put nothing in and I'll say
hey thanks that's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna wrap up me there's got to be a
there's got to be a condition that's
called something where you can't open
yeah yeah that is like definitely like
it's a real drama but like yeah there's
some Trump should attached to that for
sure you see kids just open [__] like
they're out of their minds now it's
crazy and yeah well that's even I mean
arguably that's also a disorder but
that's one where we're just like okay
with it where it's just you know like
buyers well also people buy themselves
stuff that feel better and then it goes
away yeah or like the people that would
do Amazon and uh buy things and then
send them back oh [__] I didn't even
know that's a thing well also there's
the whole thing where it's like people
unbox [__] and people on YouTube will
watch people open [__] for their
reaction yeah like it's like fetishizing
like sort of the gift giving like it is
really weird you know because it is like
it I do think when I was there's this
video
of these kids in like Africa who on
Christmas they all just get like a
stuffed whale and like when they open
their little present they like lose
their [__] minds and they're just
like oh my God look at what you can do
with it and then you watch kids in this
country and you're just like yeah they
don't give a [__] there's no value all
so all the guys I grew up with
married girls from where we grew up with
and Anne was different animals for Fort
Lauderdale [__] loud
you know and when mine was like five or
around their winter birthday party in
Simi Valley and when they brought the
cake out mine got excited because they
brought the cake out and all the other
kids were like [__] tranquilized that
[__] Cuckoo's Nest of kids
and mine's like the cakes jumping up and
down and the guy's wife said well she's
so excited and goes it's a cake
kids get excited when they see cake and
all they look is uh wait a minute did
you like the cake huh
they were like [__] little droopers
or little dogs
hello they're all sad right they opened
the door didn't be in there hello yeah
uh and none of them excited they blow
out the candle take [__] 10 pops
right here
you gotta push the stomach
[Laughter]
I mean just you came you grew up with
they they would first of all all they
did was try to subdue you not like hey
isn't this exciting they go hey [__]
relax it's the opposite of excitement
yeah that's weird the houses are far hey
hey calm down calm down we know we got
it all right everyone think we can
[__] see smoke yeah
blow it out blow the house out my
grandfather put [__] those wrought
iron uh guards on the window and they
didn't have a latch to get out Jesus
Christ my window you're here
[__] welding but they're welding it
to the house oh my God and through the
window I said well how are we supposed
to get out that's a problem for later
George my grandfather goes that [__]
you go out all the time you do good for
you to [__] stay home I'm talking
about in a fire [__] good for
you have a nice night at home when
you're in a fire what if we're the
[__] house is on fire hey well I
guess that's it huh they'll melt no
latch no [__] nothing that is crazy I
mean and going hard in the [__] house
is all burned from the side yeah [__]
the weld over the well bang yeah [__]
[__] my [__] molten [__]
wow like somebody's gonna come and take
the [__] window the iron off yeah
right right I mean crazy [__] Mexicans
do man look at white people have a latch
you know yeah [__] pull this here
yeah okay our safe word as a family our
safe word we know the Rendezvous point
right girls we know the Rendezvous Point
pine tree two that's what we mean under
there
the [__] alert
but uh but it is crazy guys and now and
now kids everything's well everything's
everything's videoed yeah everything is
staged yeah the the the to me one of the
stupidest [__] things I've ever seen
is when the the bride and the father
dance oh yeah at the at the at the
wedding yeah
I've seen a bunch of those yeah and it's
always the father you know it's like the
[__] you know like he's doing
[__] calisthenics yeah it's a [__]
Footloose some [__] [__] that's
yeah yeah that gets me on the side of
the Footloose Town it was like no more
dancing we're done with the dancing it's
[__] that [__] a good priest
comes all right everybody's under arrest
yeah
anybody's shaking their hips they're
under arrest enough [__] crazy man you
know when I worked during the day this
guy uh Ernie Ernie Shaw was uh little
guy he looked like the little referee
though your friend uh uh no no the the
boss was named Ernie Shaw it's very very
by the book you know Ernie Shaw oh do
this Jordan so we have a Christmas party
and Mrs Shaw
was drinking we didn't even never knew
Mrs Shaw but she's drinking with us and
as she's drinking with us she's like
Duck billing your [__] following day
you go down you're like you're like this
one Mr shirt oh hello all right all
right there's a shot take it easy she
just she dancing like this man [__]
dancing like clippers off okay oh
and so good at it like no no little
pinch goes unfucking rewarded like she's
grabbing just the tip of your head got a
little skin right there you're a little
like a little cheek like a saladito
right there that's a new skin
and I mean I mean
she went on pinching dicks nobody said
[__] man okay my question
where's Mrs Shaw at today that's your
daddy
calamari restaurant at 15. wow out there
pitching pinching dicks and in in heaven
yeah yeah
a little bit of cloud you come back with
a little clouds yeah but I mean I've
never I've seen a lot of crazy [__]
that's one of the craziest [__]
things that that's why we were all and
everybody would go and drink you go have
you danced with Mr
[__] wearing underwear
my uh what do they call his parents out
there [__] uh the Disco pants
uh
yeah but there was a name for him oh
I don't know I don't know [__] yeah I
would say bell bottoms with that no they
were bell bottom but there was a name
Hip Huggers the girls you swear
Aaron what the [__] is it uh they were
like Disco pan79
oh I want to get a pair of disco pants
I also wouldn't mind getting the uh
crab treatment
um yeah the crab
Sebastian oh you got areas you got
Sebastian hey I mean seriously the whole
night she's looking down and said wink
wink and this connecting man oh man I
just wish I'd have met her a long time
we all go back in there man like I'm
going back in all right I'm going in for
another round
I'm going for the [__] slow dance and
where was uh the Mr Ed
yeah there that's in the days where you
could [__] somebody from work
yeah and nobody had an issue yeah I used
to work nights thought ladies over in
the lab wow yeah but then you can't do
that at all now
yeah right
there was Sabria a woman that you know I
was a young you know I was like the
like the dude that comes into town like
Doc Hollywood comes to the tunnel yeah
right and uh those ladies like in their
20s or 30s
and you know you're like 19 20. yeah and
you know at night during the day both
Labs work but then at at night one lab
work and the rest of it was empty I'd go
in there yeah
in an amazing like 25 or 30 year old
used to seem old
yes like you you like and then you
that's so [__] weird dream yeah you
get but you when you were like you know
I mean you never had time to be like oh
yeah that's not like when you are that
age you're like oh yeah whatever and
then all of a sudden you're like oh then
you're like man I can't believe I was
like looking at 29 year olds like old
Hume like 30 you used to be like man
that's why we I can't imagine making it
to 30. there was a movie called The
Graduate yeah
bankrupt yeah that that movie turned me
on that that that did they show you on
did they show her naked
no I don't think they ever showed her
naked but I think her she says would
have been like it just made me right to
me
yeah I always wanted that older lady
yeah and she wasn't that well I would
say she was very different looking but
still kind of hot I also yeah she might
have been younger than him when they
shot it I think there's something like
that no Aaron okay never mind Susan
Catherine Ross from uh but she wasn't
that much not that much like and that's
the way I picture I
my girlfriend then I said all kinds of
pillows that's the way we're going to
get married so that's why we're going to
get married I'm going to be screaming
you know he'll take you up and I'm going
to take you out of there we're going to
run off and get married that's what I
always thought that but and her mother
didn't look anything like I am Bancroft
her mother hated me but I just that's
what I figured I was gonna have to steal
her because her mother hated me then the
Stifler's mom is in a movie you told me
to watch white something oh White Lotus
White Lotus and I started why because
you told me hey watch you I was gonna
watch it I got the two seasons I'm
sitting there saying I'm still hooked on
what I'm saying but why did George want
me to watch this movie I thought there
was something because uh who killed the
no the Italian chicks were hunting well
they were they had some big pits yeah
beautiful Italian chicks were hot I I
liked them but you didn't like the whole
overall thing well I didn't know why
what the specific I thought it was good
I thought it was oh yeah I thought it
was a murder mystery did Pearl watch it
too yeah and what did she say she liked
it she's hooked on it right now though
she's hooked on uh Yellowstone I've been
watching yeah Aaron no that's a big hit
uh I haven't seen it oh but everybody's
watching everybody was it good good
takes me a while to watch that they got
abroad with big butts yeah but I mean
like once like once it's on for like a
couple years then I'll get around to it
and like start watching I just watch
Eastbound and Down and bury all the
berry [__] great things Barry no oh
Barrett you'd love Barry Barry's a great
Barry is you know what
I think you start watching Barry all
right it's really good hey you watch you
watch Yellowstone you'll fall in love
with Beth she's got big bed pass that's
and she's and she's hot and she throws
her [__] around and she is she nude in
there there there's a couple of shots
where
I don't know I remember she's new semi
nude and she she's nasty she's nasty she
she goes to get married just one I'm not
going to spoil it she goes to get
married and she just type brother says
[__] it
I do let's do it and says [__] it right
there oh and they got the priest says
okay you're not married and then he said
hey can I get it right back because they
kidnapped me over here they had
kidnapped the priests just to get them
married I mean it's but what is it about
to take place in modern day
yeah yeah it's it's modern day
uh all you know nice looking vehicles
are driving it's all out in Montana in
the country it's horses
Cowboys yeah it's like the number one
show yeah everybody likes it it's a it's
a little cowboy [__] it's hot there's a
lot a lot of activity going on my
activity meaning sexual activity well
not only sexual a lot of shooting a lot
of murders there we go there's a lot of
action going on
and uh
remember when Billy Jack that do cut the
bra off the girl
I don't remember the Corvette Corvette
and the guy had a top off no then then
he like takes the knife in between and
cuts it you know Billy Jack shows up and
makes the dude drive his Corvette into
the water into the lake no there's a guy
there's an act a part in this uh
and it was just described to me in the
vehicle the other day with another
couple we were with uh some guy named
Rip that's his name in this you know
they call him rep he's the
oh yeah I did I did uh Jimmy Fallon with
that guy Cole Hauser I don't know who
yeah yeah
he's an actor that's been around I think
he might have been a kid actor too and
he says you know the the lady in the
back seats you know rip there's
something about him he's he's not that
handsome you know he's a good looking
guy he said and he's not skinny and all
muscle bound he's got a little pouch to
him
says but there's something about him and
his character is just hot in the [__]
all the [__] want him so that's what
we need to hear that I like to hear that
like that dance around the edge yeah
that's my sweet spot that's what I
looked like a Spider-Man but he's tough
yeah right he's a tough hard dude that's
why I don't have it and it's a it's a
watch it Yellowstone when uh we were in
high school uh uh one of the one of the
football players uh
Malcolm Malcolm Moore which is called
Malcolm Moore uh used to you they'd go
from football practice with the shorts
and the dudes walking [__] dick is
out like we're talking to class [__]
yeah a little follower right there right
down there right you know you know how
when the Jets fly that little thing
comes out
they get gas in the air god damn how
long Malcolm's ready to go welcome okay
okay I gotta go to football nobody's
clear for takeoff Malcolm's coming out
there I mean that [__] was
falling down like God damn what the [__]
like a [__] Apple like a [__] just
hanging with it yeah I mean and you know
we're [__] Chicago ours is little you
know yeah it gets cold I mean just even
when it's just sitting at attention yeah
but they were like what I mean you know
crazy [__] man we better guys saying
yeah
you got to make gym shorts longer yeah
yeah that was the problem well remember
I remember like when I mean I remember
how [__] weird it was when you were
in high school and you'd go into like
locker rooms and like dudes were
starting to get huge dicks and you were
just like what the [__] is going on yeah
like we shouldn't all be showering
together it was like it was like yeah it
was weird like they should there should
be some sort of like you know rite of
passage like your dick's big enough to
go the YMCA did that where the YMCA
would like split because I used to go to
the Y and they would do like seven to
ten then they'd do like 10 to 14 and
then if you were like going through
puberty you'd go in the adult one and
that made more sense because when I was
a kid when I go into the adult one I'd
be like this is I'm not prepared to see
this many pubes and dicks you know
rather you know you talk about that
when I was in junior high school that's
where we started taking showers together
yeah I don't remember looking at Dicks
as much as I did nuts some people here
were hanging [__] way low yeah we had
a buddy we used to call him Pooch but
how can we hang so low as a [__]
young guy yeah I have no idea I'm not
that's another show I'm not a doctor I
don't know why they they I just knows
say God damn look at those nuts are
hanging down so long you know what I I
found it [__] very unusual after PE
to like take a shower and go to school
with your hair go back to class with
your hair well hold that hole part of it
was super fun because you know you push
that thing for the soap and no [__]
soap would come out that two little
[__] little fuzz yeah fuzz things
yeah and they give you the timer shower
too where you just be like come on can
you not trust me like heaven was like
this big yeah yeah Malcolm could like
use two times
the guy's on one side of the [__]
time hand drive
[Music]
he's happy he's doing well I mean
I mean it's funny that that uh yeah 25
grandchildren 35 it's funny that our
guys are obsessed with tits but like
with I just you know when you see a
woman walk like they either show it off
or don't show it off yeah but like
that's part of the culture not like
dudes where tighter pants where you
could see it or not see it like oh that
guy's flat yeah but remember like a few
years ago with Jon Hamm when everyone
was like oh you can see Jon Hamm's dick
and everyone was like quit sexualizing
John Hamm's dick and you were like yeah
but that's like [__] had a
[__] fist yeah you're so power in
this [__] passion [__] it like this
man that's why they call him ham they
look like you got [__] like yeah but
you but he'd be acting you can see the
[__] water wiggle Under The
Underneath
yeah yeah
look I got that [__] Campana like a
[__] Bell but it was like that like
when that happened everyone was like
this is so weird to like talk about a
deer like well like that happens you
ever seen him you ever seen him no
you're gonna love his dick
and I think does he know yeah he knows
right yeah he knows he he was
position where he was like everyone knew
his dick was big and he had to be like
enough I don't want to field any more
questions about my hog yeah you know I
was like God you know
okay it was like I get it it's awesome
it's huge
holy Jesus yeah I mean come on
and that's you know just [__] hanging
out on the way look at that yeah he's
like a regular he's looking at his phone
like a regular guy he said he's like
Malcolm
wow I mean
I mean it really is crazy how clear that
is
I mean then honestly
we're talking you can see head oh Lord
wait did I show that one to the wife
tonight yeah yeah don't show her again
don't let her know that's out there
so John's Dick's on set but John's gonna
be 20 minutes yeah
I mean look at that yeah
I think the [__] pedals are in there
too you want to see a tattoo of it
some old guy in an airplane wearing
shorts oh boy and the guy the other
parent said hey look what I took a
picture of oh man and a guy's sitting
there waiting for older guy and he's you
can see he had a tattoo his shorts are
here or one like and the head of a dick
is coming out at the bottom of the at
the bottom of the shores oh my God the
tattoo that he had put on oh man you
can't I mean on a plane I know I don't
know I saw a guy watching porn on a
plane once oh that's [__] nuts yeah
what was he made it sounds like it's a
bad thing I'm sorry what was he doing no
he wasn't on the wife he was just like
what like muted watching porn before
like when everyone's getting prepared to
take off and he just had like porn on
his phone and was like comfortably
watching it and like was trying to hide
it but I was like behind and I was like
this is [__] crazy what is that dude
what I mean it's that like we're so
desensitized to this [__] where it
doesn't feel strange to be doing these
things that are like like that has got
to be like private and that to me I was
like there are a lot of gray areas where
you're like yeah you can't who knows
you're gonna turn your phone up yeah he
was like hold on I just got to finish
this call yeah
hold on how do you get on the United
Wi-Fi oh my God Miss could you help me
this guy's about to nut
um but yeah and I was just like like
that to me was like okay we gotta like I
mean I'm all for like freedom but I was
like this is not okay yeah you can't be
watching no no no no porn on a you can't
be watching porn we can't get to the
point where it's like okay for people to
be watching porn in public just from a
general standpoint of like I don't want
to watch someone be a like feel erotic
about what's on their phone or you know
one time and found my stash stash of
porn right and wherever it was stopped
was like oh that's what you like that's
brutal because after you
so this is a while I mean obviously it's
your [__] DNA wow so this is what you
like that is amazing
your lady one time can't come home from
washers I found your porn I said I don't
have anything thank God I thought I lost
it and she says no I found it
videotapers I don't have any videotaped
porn here in the house and she says I
found it it was in the TV and I found in
the video thing and there was a I said
well maybe it was probably your son you
know doing that late night [__] you know
probably you're probably distorted
copyright up and she says no it's not
sophomore this is Hardcore yeah I said
let me see it she says no I threw it
away I said well Goddamn why'd you throw
it away evidence you know just should I
threw it away I don't want it in my
house all right so it's gone
I come home the next day she as I found
out
it belonged to some friend of my sons
and my son just said oh I just borrowed
it just to look at it I said see and you
were blaming me I said so wait a minute
he saw it I thought you said you threw
it away well I hadn't thrown away I just
didn't want it in the house so I gave it
to him to give back to his friend uh I
said oh come on saying I borrowed it
because I just want to see it it's like
yeah you wanted to watch porn yeah when
I were during the day in the 80s it was
a coach a guy brought me a VHS of porn
and it's the worst thing that I wish
he'd never brought it why because after
that I couldn't stop watching porn oh
really yeah I was I'm fine without it
yeah I am too I've I took a long break
from watching porn and then if I like
every now and then I'll watch it now and
it is like after having like four years
away and like watching it after like
four or five years you're like man it
got really [__] up in that like time
off because so much of it first of all
like even the ads on the side yeah like
it's like I don't want to watch Marge
Simpson get [__] by the Family Guy Dad
I'm good you know yeah but then it's
also like so much stuff is like first of
all the look is just aesthetically the
people what about now that they can put
your face have you seen it where like
the the dude like the girl from behind
and you can put a box there you can put
your face on the girl's face what a
fleet what why would you want it yeah
I'm a girl where you're the bent over
and I put them back
and then he's gonna put it in a VCR
you can you can stop why would you even
want that isn't that I would want that
like going Beyond like part of it is
that like it's a whole AI thing I know
but it's like you gotta like I mean you
gotta like think about having real sex
and keeping that is like the best yeah
anything that's what I think and then so
it's like when you do that sort of [__]
then you're just going like well if you
if you can beat regular [__] you
shouldn't be doing that
that's the line uh can we make that the
slogan of the podcast Aaron make it
happen also can we bring up Jon Hamm's
dick on this monitor when you get a
second thanks or and uh print some stuff
out like apple you can make a
screensaver or yeah a a holder for your
phone if you can print it on some shirts
that'd be awesome I think we should have
John hems um yeah you better go be the
pass to get in come here it is I think I
feel like there's some resistance coming
from in the 70s guys guys might like
that all the time
in the 70s with the the jeans yeah right
just you could see I never had something
that big so I don't know yeah but guys
guys did that [__] in album covers you
ever seen an avocado where you can see
it guys that's like spinal tap where
they would be like they would put yeah
the [__] foil Cube numbers in there
in the in the 70s those guys did that
where and that was part which is so
weird because it's like part of the rock
I know but still a part of rock doesn't
need to be rock hard right that would be
like that is like so how much bigger
could that thing get if it was wrong
hard John Hamm's yeah show them the
picture
let me know
we didn't know you wanted to see it hard
Gil we got Aaron bring that over we got
it it's on two different screens
it's like a mounted fish we gotta bring
it in we got three guys lifting it
they're Union it's like a mounted fish
it's like a barracuda let's see here's
here's one uh
Sticky Fingers Rolling Stones but there
was one word Journey
the guys in Journey had it uh that's
Steve Perry
see that's the problem yeah that's why
you said Don't Stop Believing that's
about his cocky big [__] followers
yeah yeah
looks like a snake trying to get out of
a tight garbage bag oh yeah look
oh my God
Jesus Christ
I knew there was one there that guy in
Journey I like the other guys are like
hey man can you wear brown pants like
the rest of us that's what his name
by the way of course of course it's the
keyboard player he's like I'm in the
back but you know what I'm lead on [__]
I believe we don't belong
God I can't remember his name [__] it by
the way he falls right away remember his
name okay no the guy with a big dick the
keyboard and organ turns out that's some
crazy [__] man I can't remember uh oh it
doesn't matter he's he's happy with that
Legacy he's like you don't need to know
my name just know the outline that's it
just just know it
yeah
Jonathan
no the other guy uh
Greg Raleigh
thank you wow yes you don't know
Jonathan King little tiny pie yeah he
came after he came after uh Greg Raleigh
left yeah oh yeah big pants big pants
all in white pants yeah Val appreciate
it man that was awesome dude I
appreciate it wearing white pants all of
them were in white pants I got trouble
for you in the car yeah no I really am
like such a huge fan also like dude I
really appreciate it what's the like are
you is it that easy like does it because
you're [__] hilarious man like just
it just comes into you right yeah I
don't think it's anything you could
teach anybody
maybe just to open your mind and let let
your mind be open yeah I think I think
it I mean I'm again man like I'm I'm
very like lucky that
um you know I got like comfortable being
you know when you're [__] just all
step up the top of his head man great
right now tonight yes yeah but no I mean
again like that is it is like for me
what is great is to be able to like talk
to people that I think are [__]
amazing and like my podcast is basically
that like my podcast the dollop so if
people like listen to me be like a
[__] weirdo you can go listen to
dollop you know but it's also like I I
like talk and when you're talking to
good people like you just enjoy the [__]
out of it so that's it's really you know
doing this I was never really
comfortable in conversation for that
long you know so it really has helped me
in my other stuff because I could do
this for two hours where I thought
before I thought but you're also a great
like a great I mean I think very funny
but also like a great interviewer I
think the way you do this podcast is
also like a way that is
it really is like free-flowing and like
enjoyable as [__] so yeah you know we're
good man thank you yeah appreciate it
thank you yes thank you and then um
we'll go get those hand tattoos oh yeah
what if you go buy pants with it already
in there yeah
I'm looking for some pants pre-hand
I just got some in uh all the whites are
gone of course
all right everyone thanks Sam